NASA's Mars rover spirit past its
six-year anniversary January 3rd
but the upcoming Mars winter may spell
the end for the all-terrain vehicle
last year spirits wheels broke through a
crusty Mars surface layer and became
trapped in the loose sand hidden
underneath here
a NASA scale-model mock-up is seen
trying to maneuver out of the
predicament latest attempts to recover
the real Rover have resulted in it
sinking deeper in the Martian soil
spirits twin rover Opportunity landed on
the opposite side of Mars
three weeks after spirit and is still
able to Rove across the planet's surface
the two Rovers combined have traveled
more than 16 miles sending back photos
and lots of data about the planet as
daily sunshine on the red planet
southern hemisphere declines with the
approaching winter NASA ground operators
are trying to adjust the tilt of spirits
solar panels to compensate for the
decrease in solar energy right now the
solar panels are pointed slightly south
it's in its approaching winter and for
the best sunlight it should be pointed
in the other direction
toward the north where the Sun will be
above the horizon unless the tilt is
improved and an unexpected gust of
Martian wind can clean off dust
accumulation on its solar panels spirits
power will continually decline until May
and the rover could become totally
inoperable but NASA scientists say the
rover's far outlasted their expected
life of just 90 days something that
lasts almost six years when it was only
supposed to last 90 days you got to be
joyful that that thing has been so
tremendously successful in some ways the
idea that it may be stuck in one place
is sad and that it can't Rove anymore
but on the other hand it's still alive
there are some science that it can do
that it couldn't do as a rover and so
that's in fact something look forward to
and as exciting
Meyer says by being stationary spirit
can make extremely fine measurements
using its radio and it can monitor minor
variations in the spin of Mars he says
by doing that for an extended time
scientists will be able to tell if Mars
has a liquid Center or a solid Center